I think you just try to stay true to the
tube to reality as far as what kids that
age are thinking about and feeling and
worried about and how they relate to one
another and speak to one another and
yeah I mean a lot of the movie is them
you know reacting to the adult world
they themselves are not like
perpetuating a lot of the dirty kind of
elements of the movie they're kind of
more surrounded by them which which of
the kid is very you know very true to
one more in sixth grade now we are doing
sixth grade things I know what cocaine
is only you look I like just the sipping
a beer sequence in the beginning of the
film because I just remember those
moments and it was like such a big deal
and it's no matter what your first sip
is just and I just remember the build-up
to it I feel like they captured the
intensity of the kid having a
precipitate everyone blistered everyone
like learns who they are and kind of has
to deal with the anxiety of like leaving
in a younger simpler life and going into
high school middle school and I fall
from the points with
I'm 1/2 1/2 Brady half Lukas oh my god
there's Molly in there ok
who's Molly cuz she's not with oxidases
Christ it was so much fun and you shall
get to work with Keith n Brady in yeah I
had a blast I would say the innocent
this is kind of my favorite
I like how we bet we also barely know
even like the words that we're saying
and like how are they yeah it's
completely something that's never been
done before I'm sure we're happy to be a
part of it awesome that's awesome super
funny super quick-witted really helpful
throughout Europe throughout everything
[Music]
you